hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focus Channel and my name is Paul what
languages does the Pope speak I want to
talk about polyglot Pope's when you
think of the Pope you might think of a
very holy person and a religious person
someone who sits around praying all day
or something like that but think about
it to be the leader of a huge
organization like the Catholic Church
you have to be a very success -
individual so let's look at a few recent
Pope's and see where they rate on the
polyglot scale first let's talk about
the current Pope Pope Francis who became
the Pope in 2013 he is originally from
Argentina and he speaks Spanish fluently
as his native language he also speaks
Italian fluently he learned Italian as a
kid when he was in Argentina from his
father and his grandparents who were
Italian immigrants and early on when he
became the Pope at the beginning he
would only speak Italian in public for
the media or in front of audiences
Italian is the lingua franca of the
Vatican and it's the most commonly
spoken language in the Vatican and also
he is the Archbishop of Rome so it makes
sense that he would speak Italian the
language of his own locality I've also
heard reports from Brazilian people that
went Pope Francis visited Brazil he
spoke fluently in Portuguese although
with a heavy Argentinian accent and
apparently the Pope speaks also German
and French but is getting rusty due to a
lack of use Pope Francis also admits
that he's had quite a hard time learning
English in large part due to English
phonology which he finds hard during a
three-month stay in Ireland when he
tried to learn English he had some
trouble although I must say I can't
blame him for being confused by the
Irish people's funny pronunciation
sorry Irish people just kidding after
being the Pope for a little over a year
Pope Francis spoke English in public for
the first time in Seoul Korea
are you ready to say yes are you ready
so clearly Pope Francis is working on
his English and he's improving it to be
able to do his duties better around the
world of course he also knows Latin
which is used for ceremonial purposes
and for official documents in the
Vatican a part of his studies was also
to learn Biblical Hebrew and biblical
Greek which are necessary for Bible
studies so Pope Francis speaks Spanish
Italian Portuguese some German some
French some English and three literary
languages for a total polyglot score of
six out of ten that's pretty darn good
by the way but he's up against some
stiff competition so I can't give him
ten out of ten
next is Pope Benedict the sixteenth who
was the Pope from 2005 until 2013 when
he resigned he is known for being more
of a legitimate polyglot than Pope
Francis his native language is German
but he is also known to fluently speak
Italian French English and Spanish I've
also read reports that he speaks
Portuguese but not totally fluently but
he's very good at Latin and used Latin
more than Pope Francis currently does as
Pope and of course he can also read
Biblical Hebrew and biblical Greek but
again they're not spoken languages those
are just classical written languages
pope benedict's made waves in 2013 when
he resigned as the pope which is almost
completely unheard of and he made waves
partly because his announcement was in
latin the reporter who broke the story
to the world ended up being the only
reporter in the Vatican press office who
could understand the original report in
Latin so let's recap for pope benedict
xvi he speaks German Italian Spanish
French and English fluently he also
speaks some Portuguese and he speaks
Latin and he knows to literary languages
Greek and Biblical Hebrew for a total
polyglot score of seven out of ten but
the king of polygon Pope's is without a
doubt pope john paul ii who was the pope
from 1978 until his death in 2005 pope
john paul ii was originally from poland
so his native language was polish but he
was also fluent in Italian Spanish
Portuguese French and English as well as
Latin of course Pope John Paul the
second is also known for
good working knowledge of some other
languages at least enough to speak
publicly in those languages with some
preparation those languages include
Slovak Russian Ukrainian Japanese
Tagalog among many others at the end of
one Easter Mass he once gave an Easter
greeting in 57 different languages
maybe he loved languages so much because
he was also an avid traveler he visited
129 different countries which is more
than any other Pope in history
so to recap Pope John Paul the second
was fluent in Polish Italian Spanish
Portuguese French English and German and
Latin and he knew a whole bunch of other
languages better than most language
dabblers out there so he gets a total
polyglot score of 10 out of 10 whether
you're a Catholic or not pope john paul
ii was clearly an inspiring polyglot and
his language lovers we can look up to
and admire that aspect of his life and
his work thank you for watching the lang
focused channel have a good night